dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here consider
this problem we have a pair of images
that are visually quite different but
have similar semantic meanings and we
wish to map points between them now this
might sound a bit weird so bear with me
for a moment
for instance geese and airplanes look
quite different but both have wings and
front and back regions the paws of a
lion looks quite different from a cat's
foot but they share the same function
and are semantically similar this is an
AI base technique that is able to find
these corresponding points between our
pair of images in fact the point pairs
you've seen so far have been found by
this AI the main difference between this
and previous non learning based
techniques is that instead of pairing up
regions based on pixel color
similarities it measures how similar
they are in terms of the neural networks
internal representation this makes all
the difference so far this is pretty
cool but is that it mapping points well
if we can map points effectively we can
map regions as a collection of points
this enables two killer applications one
this can augment already existing
artistic tools so that we can create a
hybrid between two images and the cool
thing is that we don't even need to have
any drawing skills because we only have
to add these colored masks and the
algorithm finds and stitches together
the corresponding images
and - it can also perform cross-domain
image morphing that's an amazing term
but what does this mean this means that
we have our pair of images from earlier
and we are not interested in stitching
together a new image from their parts
that we want an animation where the
starting point is one image the ending
point is the other and we get a smooth
and meaningful transition between the
two there are some really cool use cases
for this for example we can start out
from a cartoon drawing set our photo as
an end point and witness this beautiful
morphing between the two kind of like in
star transfer but we have more
fine-grained control over the output
really cool and note that many images in
between are usable as is no artistic
skills needed and of course there is a
mandatory animation that makes a cat
from a dog as usual there are lots of
comparisons to other similar techniques
in the paper this tool is going to be
invaluable for I was about to say
artists but this doesn't require any
technical expertise just good taste and
a little bit of imagination what an
incredible time to be alive thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time